foreign
[Music]
so
I do a lot of exploratory data analysis
and a lot of that flow is built around
built a reading data into memory the
first step is we import some data before
we can transform visualize model it and
if you're in this room it's because it
might be uh this database is track it
might be because a lot of the time it's
not where the data we need is
in a lot of organizations we work with
data that's in a database MySQL postgres
snowflake SQL server and a lot of those
exciting data analyzes don't start from
reading a CSV into memory they start by
hitting data that's in SQL
I have a strong belief that working with
a database should be as easy for your
team as possible last couple years has
been a lot of attention to how can we
build our packages that make working
with that make working within a company
really smooth they really help people
get get to the data that matters for
their team for the team and
Uh I that first kind of really hit me
when I was in my first data scientist
role at stack Overflow so when I first
got in there I was the first R user and
I I ended up building a an internal
package called SQL stack r
that was uh that managed kind of a
connecting and working with the data in
those databases and every job I've had
since I've built some similar iteration
onto that uh onto that same template of
creating a database of a package that
wraps a database connection
so now um and now we've open sourced it
as DB Cooper so DB Cooper is an uh it
started as an r package named after the
famous band at the hijacker DB Cooper
and uh I'm excited to share the wild
starters in our package Michael Chow is
actually ported it to python so now it
was both a DB Cooper R and python
version
and what they do is make it one step to
create a database specific packages so
if you're at a company widgets Inc you
can use DB Cooper to create an internal
package like widget r or widget pi to
help analysts fluidly access the data in
your databases
let's talk about the problem that it's
solving mostly today I'm going to be
talking from the perspective of the r
package but a lot of these uh these same
uh problems and solutions exist in the
python version so what's it like to work
with a database from r
what might you need to do when you're
analyzing data in a database
some common tasks you might need to list
the the tables that are in the database
you might want to transform tables using
deep deep IR so DB plyo is a really
powerful package it lets you work with a
remote table kind of as if it were an
in-memory table and who here's use DB
plier
really uh it is a really fun experience
isn't it we sometimes can't just use DB
player we want to run our custom SQL
queries so we want to construct SQL uh
select statements ourselves and try
running them
and sometimes we need to execute a
command like creating a table or
dropping a table
so I'll give an example here of how we
might work with a SQL connection so this
is a database called lamin it's based on
the lamin baseball statistics data set a
really phenomenal collection of tables
and it comes built into DB player so
we've got this lamin DB object it's a
SQL connection
and
let's start with how might we go about
listing tables we use the DB list tables
function from DBI would get us a vector
of the tables in the database
if we wanted to work with a remote table
as if it were a DB player table we'd use
the table function TBL on this database
we want to get one of the tables out of
it in the case of the lamin data I might
be interested in its table on batting
statistics
if I want to run a SQL query I'd still
use the table function but now I could
use the SQL function to actually
construct that query so here I might be
writing a query where I'm counting the
batting table grouped by player ID and
getting back some results from it
and if I want to execute a command I
might use the DB execute function
so these four approaches that they
they work they uh they they do what they
what they're supposed to do but
something really bothers me about them
something is just fundamentally a little
bit harder to use than out than I would
expect to be something is they're not
they're not designed how I'd want to
work with this uh this data I'm really
trying to figure out what is bothering
me about these these functions and I'll
say I think that uh let's say if I load
up this database what really is bugging
me is that lamin DB object
like in our environment we've got this
lamin DB object it's a SQL connection
object and
I don't know what that is that's the
route for me that's the wrong level of
abstraction I want to be working with
individual tables I want to be I want to
directly uh writing SQL queries and
immediately executing them I don't
necessarily I don't know how I'm going
to pass this connection around it's a
clumsy way to engage with a database
so that's why I see that I think there's
a missing puzzle piece in between DBI
for creating a connection to a database
and DB player for transforming and
exploring those tables
foreign
Cooper comes in it turns a database into
an opinionated collection of functions
to let us explore it really fluidly kind
of as if it were data that were in
memory
DB Cooper takes you only need to do one
function called the setup DB Cooper it's
DBC in net you pass it the connection
object and you give it a prefix if
you've worked with a lot of our packages
you know how useful it can be to have a
shared prefix
dbca Nets stores and manages the
connection globally it generates a
prefixed function for important tasks
you would do with that database and
really importantly it generates
autocomplete friendly accessors for
tables
so I'll show how each of those tasks
would be achieved in DB Cooper once
you've run DBC and net
instead of doing DB list tables I would
just do lamin underscore list so that
prefix that I passed it turned into a
prefix for the function Lam and list
would return the the list of of tables
that are in the database
so lament if I want to access just one
table I use lamin underscore TBL so if I
say in Lawman TBL then I can pass it the
name of table get that one back
if we want to run a query I do lamin
underscore query and pass the SQL
and if I wanted to execute I'd use lamin
underscore execute
it's one thing to notice about this is
it's taking the connection object
entirely out of the picture
and it's focusing on an opinionated set
of tasks that someone might want to do
with a database
my favorite feature about DB Cooper is
autocomplete so instead of so whenever
I've worked with a database it can be
hard to remember what the tables are and
I get kind of tired of constantly
referring back to the um to the
documentation or even to a list function
to see what they are and I'm I don't
like I would maybe run the typos Etc and
um it just doesn't feel anything like
working with data that's in memory
so DB Cooper creates a one function for
each of the tables in your database
so you can access them with autocomplete
it's a much more fluid experience where
I can say where if I go into a table I
can just start typing in and see oh yeah
here are the tables that um I can't
remember exactly what this table and my
database is called but I use
autocomplete to help me out
one thing I like about that is it makes
the something like a complicated join uh
much more concise and much easier to
read for me it kind of again it really
means I don't have to remember that I'm
working with SQL tables uh using DB
plier with remote tables can feel a lot
like using dpir with local tables
so I've been showing examples of the r
function what Michael Chow has set up is
really something phenomenal which is DB
Cooper Pi where each where each of the T
it has the same Auto Syntax for creating
list table query and execute
but it also takes advantage of his super
package Suba is a a python Port of D of
D pi r that supports both local pandas
data frames and data and databases so
here you can actually see that the um
that we could we could use the the lamin
data and say um dot TBL with the
salaries and then pipe to count but all
within python so one thing I think is
great about super is if you're really if
you're really familiar with dply r and
you're and you're interested in going
over to python soup is absolutely the
way to do it and DB Cooper in Python is
a way to use that in your in your
databases
I'm going to show an example of
exploring a database using DB Cooper
this is the New York Times covid-19
database
Google makes public a large set of data
of databases of let's say 239 databases
in Google bigquery
so this is a phenomenal resource because
that means there are 239 packages you
could uh you could write wrapping each
of these data sources I'm going to show
one which is the New York Times covid-19
database
so we'd start by creating the connection
DB Cooper doesn't help with this we
created ourselves using DBI uh dbconnect
really whatever approach we would
generally use to create a database
connection
and then all we have to do with uh with
DB Cooper is DBC and net and we'll say
we'll use the prefix covid so all of our
functions are going to use to access are
going to start with the word covid
so now that I have done DBC init I could
use covid list if I want to say okay
there are four tables in this database
and if I want to access one of them I
could uh say Okay covid underscore US
states now I've got this autocomplete
friendly uh way to access one of the
tables and we see data that looks like
it's a Time series it might separate
across each of the U in the US states
it's got um it's got both a column for
confirmed cases and deaths my
understanding gets updated daily so we
can we could build something on top of
this that would uh that unlike a static
data set is going to stay up to date
and now that I've got it I can work with
this data as if it were local I can work
with it and
I can filter I can arrange I can do
visualizations so I can let's say we
pipe it through this is actually all of
this aggregation this fill to this range
this mutate was all turned into a SQL uh
SQL query gets run gets brought into
memory only when we plot it
and this is something I really like
about DB Cooper is like I just forget
I'm using it as soon as you've got these
tables you kind of just go right back
into your normal flow I never liked when
I worked with SQL databases that I'd
have to take one step to do the select
and the collect and now I'm working in
my traditional exploratory data analysis
flow here you can basically you can
barely tell where the database ends and
where your uh your exploratory data
analysis begins
would DB Cooper really shines is in
creating an opinionated package around a
database
so give an example it's um as I said I
first developed this kind of approach
while I was working at stack Overflow so
it's appropriate that we set up a
package that wraps a public stack
Overflow database which is one of the
one of the big queried public databases
is stack Overflow questions answers tags
so around this database we set up
the the stack big query package this is
a package I put up just an example of a
package that could be created we picked
the database now let's wrap it with it
with a package and the way that we'd go
about doing that is three steps first we
write database specific connection code
so anything in terms of setting up
credentials Etc that's gonna that's
gonna live in inside this package
then critically in the dot the dot on
load and Dot uh on um on unload
functions those are functions that run
every time a package is uh loaded or
unloaded we're going to create one of
those database connections
and then use DBC and net so this means
that as soon as somebody loads in this
package it's gonna it's gonna populate
that package's name space with functions
that start with that prefix stack
now every database is different and the
ways we explore them are different too
so the next step
would be adding database specific verbs
something that I love to do with stack
Overflow data is look at say patterns of
trends of tags over time I'm really
interested in can I aggregate at the tag
level that requires joining together a
couple tables in the database and doing
a little bit of custom logic that kind
of custom database specific logic or
problem specific logical company
specific logic is really good fit for a
package that uses DB Cooper because it's
going to mean that the when the person
using this package actually does this
analysis
it's gonna everything's gonna be set up
for them so when you do library stack
big query now we've got a function stack
underscore for any of the we've got
stack list stacked uh table stack uh
execute stack query and one one of these
functions for each of the table
accessors so basically by loading
Library it's as if every table just got
loaded right into their environment so
they can use it
here's an example of an analysis that I
would do
here we go so here's an example of an
analysis that I would do for instance
other tags over time so this is an
aggregation that compares a couple of
Technologies like python JavaScript Java
and R in terms of the percentage of
stack Overflow questions each each uh it
was done by a month uh by month that are
had with this particular language
so he we can um no notice there's a
there's a use of that summarized tags
function that's database specific and
then there's just some DB uh some deep
pliers some ggplot2 and again really
quickly you can forget that you're
working with the database at all
so what I learned from the DB Cooper
package is kind of really two two
takeaways one is don't underestimate the
value of small usability improvements
that affect you every day
and second is that a good database
package lets you forget about the
package entirely
see once we've got this this data loaded
it's really as if we just had notice
instead of looking at that one
connection object and now we're always
working with that connection object now
we're just working with all the tables
in the database
so next time you're working with the
database connection it just takes one
line uh you uh try to be Cooper and I'd
love to hear what you think thank you
[Applause]
[Music]